we've had 10 lead changes all in the
second half
clippers up by two george gets around
shamit
plus one the discard of his former
teammate
and a chance at a three-point play and
the clippers have extended their lead to
five
george with 21 points durant pull up
it's there but forced calendared into a
tough shot
kyrie irving from downtown
[Applause]
irving pep in his step oh the corkscrew
off the euro kyrie irving is locked in
the nets take a two-point lead
an elusive move from kyrie
[Music]
kyrie irving 34 points
leonard short on a three rebounded by
harris
net 7-0 run kyrie irving has
37 points but two misses on a three ball
we approach four minutes to go
in the fourth james harden got a three
in the corner on that play you give the
ball to harden this time and he
able to finish and convert but
here's leonard makes his move on the
inside
pump fake oh the strength of leonard
a chance at a three-point play strong
leonard able to turn the corner great
ball fake right here frozen
absorbing the contact and kawaii
29. now durant
wants to get in on the act durant's
jumper is good
rebounds it and clears under two minutes
to play
durant wants to dance with batoon a
three
kevin durant a downtown hit
wow big time shot by k.d all you can say
is wow
but tomb answers with a triple
jackson waits we are under a minute left
morris wants to take it over irving for
two
and a foul great patience
attacking the smaller defender
irving backs off jackson gets it in
georgia three
it's good paul george on
target it's a one point game
but what a big time shot right here
contested
george gathers his feet steps up big
time shot
let's find themselves in another
potentially hairy situation
harden goes long green ball fake layup
is good and a foul
with 5.5 hardin throws the touchdown
pass
to jeff green brooklyn in the same
position they were in
two nights ago jeff green wide open and
it looked like he didn't even really
want to shoot that right there but
knocks down the layup great pass by
hardin
another might have shooters hovering but
it's important
that platoon make this first free throw
of course for brooklyn you have to block
out
and secure the defensive possession here
no good
and that will make life more difficult
for la 122-119
the tomb gets the bounce on the second
attempt
to advance the ball and harden
will toss it in
looking bounces for irving foul gibbon
with 1.9
and steve nash with these sideline out
of bound play
clearing everybody down the court just
having a two on two game and
irving able to get open quick trap
opportunity paul george
felt like it wasn't a foul
but here is simple if ervin knocks down
these two free throws
game over nets win
kyrie irving is shooting it at 94
at the free-throw line he has one of one
tonight
that's up by two nets up by three
trying to seal it with
1.9 to play
he does 124 to 120.
the battle in brooklyn belongs to the
nets
they outlast the clippers 124
and who knows